don't make a plan that is what you
should do make a plan that outlines a
future so that you can sit back and say
look if I had that future then all the
horrible things that are going to happen
to me are going to be worthwhile that's
what you want do you want to think this
game is worth playing despite its
tragedy that's what you've got in life
enough meaning to serve as an antidote
to tragedy and then you generate a
strategy the other thing you should do
if you're not very industrious is
discipline yourself eat three times a
day at regular meal times that's a good
thing to practice because that starts to
put some stability into your life get up
at the same time I would highly
recommend all those young people out
there who are listening you want to get
a jump on life get the hell out of bed
in the morning as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline get up
early in the morning and get your things
done learn to get up at six in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
and so that's a massive massive
Advantage hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Jordan
Peterson and how to become the person
you've always wanted to be
enjoy
look Will Ferrell Warren Farrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make forty percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra 10 or
extra 13 have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the Pareto distribution
so
and get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also helps you plan what you
want to do so I could say well lay out
your damn calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a bit that's hell that's
a bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it and or or aim for the
opposite because that's how you get out
of it rule number two deal with your
inadequacies the adventure of your life
you say imagine who you could be and
then aim single-mindedly at that
um I encounter these young people who
appear to know who they could be or
they've imagined who they could be but
for whatever reason they seem to choose
the certain misery of their current
situation the job that's sucking their
soul out or that relationship over the
uncertainty they'll encounter as they go
on the adventure of their life so what
would I say to these young people who
always say to me Steve I I want to do
this but you can see them stifled by
fear because it's like yeah well it's
like make a plan man it's so when I was
doing my clinical work which I I did a
lot of career work with my clients both
at a beginner level I would say like
really a beginner level with people who
had no employment whatsoever no history
of employment we're undereducated and
who lacked every skill you could
possibly imagine these are people who
are really in Dire Straits up to people
who were operating at the top of their
profession but who could still
strategize forward and so
for example let's say you're at a dead
end in your job okay so I don't find my
work meaningful all right so that's a
problem statement it's like well why not
I find the work I do repetitive and
boring and without spirit I have a bad
relationship or a neutral relationship
with my boss who doesn't know who I am I
have problems with co-workers all of
that needs to be differentiated right
and analyzed in detail so we might say
for example let's say you believe that
you're undervalued at work
and maybe you are what you need to do is
you have something to say and we would
have to figure out what it is that you
have to say but it would be some variant
of I'm bringing more value to the table
than I am being compensated for and
that's demoralizing me and it's also not
good for you you being my boss because
if I'm actually more valuable than is
being recognized then the fact that
you're not valuing me properly means
that I will become demoralized I won't
work properly and you won't get the best
out of me so it's bad for both of us and
if your boss is in principle not
amenable to such a discussion then what
you should seriously consider doing is
finding another job
okay so let's say we're going to set you
up for this okay this isn't like next
week's Enterprise man this is your life
so the first thing I would ask is well
do you have your resume or CV in order
well I haven't typed it up for three
years
well what do you think about bringing it
up well I'm pretty nervous about that
because there's some holes in it and you
know I didn't do so well in college and
I'm kind of embarrassed about my resume
it's like okay bring it in let's go
through it let's let's let's at least
update it let's look where the holes are
let's look at where the inadequacies are
as far as you're concerned right this
isn't my judgment it's your judgment
let's walk through those judgments and
see if they're warranted because maybe
you're just too guilty and ashamed and
self-conscious and anxious and you're
not you're looking at your resume more
critically than someone else would and
maybe there's some holes that you need
to rectify you know you're you're at
you're you were two courses away from
your ba and you dropped out or something
like that well
maybe we need six months to address that
and at least even if you can't be fully
educated you could be taking some
courses online and so when you went to a
new job interview and they said what
about this whole you'd say well I I came
to terms with that six months ago and
then an effort to rectify it I'm taking
the following courses and here's my plan
for completion that's a really good
answer and anyone with any sense who's
interviewing will accept that as an
indication that although you're not
perfect and who is that you have a good
plan and that you've thought it through
like that's the kind of answer that in
all likelihood we'll cement your
candidacy for the position okay so now
you're going to go to your boss well you
have to have your CV and your resume in
order and you have to be able to stand
on it solidly and which at least means
that you're prepared to address the
inadequacies in a credible realistic
believable and truthful manner all right
now what you do is apply for like 10
jobs
you don't have to take them
but maybe you have to go to an interview
or two or three or four and maybe
there's a bunch of opportunities out
there for you that you didn't even know
about
and maybe someone offers you a job
and so now now you can go to your boss
and say
here's the situation I'm in here at work
um here's my evaluation of the problems
in relationship to me here's what I
could do for you if you gave me a 40
raise and the opportunity to progress
but I'd like to see a plan for that and
um I've been looking for other
opportunities before conducting this
discussion and I have some
well then if your boss treats you with
contempt at that point and doesn't
listen then perhaps he or she is a
little more narcissistic than might be
optimal and it's time to find a new job
but this isn't something you do
trivially and so when you're doubtful
say you're trapped
you ask yourself well
why am I trapped that's a hard question
right because some of it's your own
inadequacy a lot of it and all of the
part of it that you can deal with is
your own inadequacy
so even if it's unfair you know even if
you're hemmed in for any number of
reasons
inappropriate
like ethnically predicated oppression
let's say or maybe you live it you're in
a workplace that really is sexist in
some fundamental sense well
that's not good it's not just it's not
fair it's it's not meritorious all of
those things men maybe you shouldn't be
there but
what you can do to begin with is every
bloody thing you possibly can do to put
yourself in the most virtuous and
Powerful negotiating position possible
and you have to think like a snake in
some sense to do that you got to get the
details right you have to be prepared to
bite and and you have to have your eyes
on the prize so to speak and people
aren't taught this sort of thing ever
really they're not taught how to
negotiate they're not taught how to goal
set they're not taught how to
conceptualize appropriate success in
some broad sense in some sense that's
what the humanities are supposed to
teach people rule number three enjoy
life
when do you feel the most loved Jordan
one what's one what's happening around
you or when you're creating something or
when you're with people when do you feel
personally the most loved
oh it's when I'm with my family when I'm
with my kids with one I'm with my family
friends too and and that's even been
more the case over the last couple of
years because my family and friends have
been so unbelievably loyal and helpful
to me and my family as we've had our
troubles terrible terrible troubles over
the last couple of years yeah they've
been so unbelievably reliable and
helpful amazing
certainly people have gone out of my way
for me in a way that I I don't believe I
would have done for them really well
look I saw my father-in-law when when
and I write about this in in Beyond
order oh no I read about it in 12 rules
more I think but it doesn't matter he's
a like he's a really extroverted guy
disagreeable guy too masculine guy
extroverted assertive everybody in the
little town I grew up in knew who he was
he was a performer you know the life of
the party
um and a good businessman but a real
character
and uh
he did his own thing but then his wife
got uh
prefrontal dementia when she was quite
young 55 and man he took care of her for
15 years wow it was unbelievable and it
was so interesting too because if we
offered to help him he would accept it
right away and anything that we could do
that would like I suggested one time for
example that he'd buy a digital readout
sign so that if he went out he could
type in where he was going on the sign
and it would just repeat over and over
oh that's cool and some recordings in
the bathroom to help his wife remember
what to do and he would just
Implement those accept and Implement
them right away but he this guy who was
who lived his own life who who was a a
very extroverted social person not
someone who you would have regarded as
soft and caring and I don't mean that in
a negative way it's just that that
wasn't him wasn't Mother Teresa you know
um he just
he cared for her in a way that was
absolutely astonishing
and I saw that also in my friends and my
family in the care that they've offered
to Tammy and I over the last two years
mind-boggling
all right
mind-boggling but I would say the like
the place I like to be the bet most is
in a family situation
when everyone's when there's no
elephants under the rug
and
everyone's playing
if you ever have that you should
consider yourself
fortunate well beyond belief because
it's unlikely and you can lose it at any
moment
yeah
I've been in I was in the hospital more
or less for a year and then another year
with Tammy
and I thought I'd lost all of that never
get it back it was very Dreadful
and so now when it happens I mean I've
always been grateful for it when it
happens
strive for that also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four Find meaning
[Music]
we must have an aim in our life
no matter what stage of life we're in
and if we don't have some type of aim
even if for a few months of an aim of
going somewhere or Direction
we're gonna the suffering's gonna be
even more suffering pointless because
we're already going to face the greatest
challenges that's right you're already
struggling that's right there's no way
adversity is coming no matter what
that's right we have big goals or small
little goal or whatever it may be but
it's going to be less suffering if we
have an aim yeah well and not only that
it's worse than that even because the
suffering is with zero meaning well the
suffering is pain and the suffering is
anxiety and uncertainty and the
suffering is hopelessness but the
consequence of all that is that you get
bitter and when you get bitter you get
mean and you get cruel and you start to
hurt yourself and other people so it's
not only that if you don't have a goal
you suffer it's that you if you don't
have a goal you suffer and then you get
cruel and bitter and resentful and then
you start to actively try to make the
world the worst place and so so because
you can't Suffer pointlessly Without
becoming bitter and you can't become
bitter without becoming cruel
so you need a name the question is then
the question of course yeah
that's for sure so then the question is
what should your aim be and we have a
program it's one of the things I wanted
to talk to you about today I I have this
website called self-authoring.com and
that program helps people write about
their life and so there's a past
authoring program to to establish your
aim you have to know where you are
it's like you're trying to orient
yourself on a map you can't Orient
yourself on a map unless you know where
you are you also have to know where
you're going right so those are the two
relevant things the past authoring
program helps people write about their
life so it's a guided autobiography we
ask people to break their life up into
six epochs six sections and then to
write about the emotionally important
events in those in those epochs and to
detail out why why the positive things
happen and why more of that could
conceivably happen in the future and to
detail out why the negative things
happen and to try to understand why with
the name two not replicating them in the
future because the purpose of memory
isn't to remember the past the purpose
of memory is so that you you figure out
what went wrong when something went
wrong so you don't duplicate it in the
future so that's the purpose of memory
and the past authoring program can help
people catch up and you know you have to
catch up if you have memories that are
older than about a year and a half that
still cause you emotional pain when you
think multiple or if you dwell on them
they come spontaneously back to mind
means you haven't it means that there's
part of your life that you haven't
mapped out properly and it still has
emotional valence that's gripping you
you're still holding onto that story or
it's still holding on to you right you
gotta let it go yeah yeah well you
haven't been able to navigate your way
through it you there's a pitfall there
that you fell in and you don't know how
to avoid similar pitfalls in the future
and that's why your brain won't let it
go because it's saying that's what the
anxiety systems do it's like this
happened to you it wasn't good this
happened to you it wasn't good this
happened to you it wasn't good fix it
fix it fix it fix it that will never go
away unless you fix it how do you fix it
well you have to figure out why it
happened right that's the first thing is
like how did you how was it that that
situation arose to pull you down and
that's not simple that's why well that's
why we have the writing program because
it's complicated to think it through but
you but if you face it and you and you
meditate on it let's say and you and you
do this voluntarily there's a pretty
high probability that you'll be able to
decrease the probability that will be
repeated in the future so
go ahead oh well well we the the second
part of the program helps people do an
analysis of their virtues and their
faults same sort of idea what's good
about you that you could capitalize on
what's weak about you that you need to
fix so that it doesn't bring you down
right and that's the present authoring
but the future authoring program is
probably most relevant to you and your
listeners because you're interested in
helping people establish aims and so we
already talked about the fact that you
need a name in Life or or that's where
you derive your meaning and without that
things go to hell and and as literally
as that can be taken and so but it's not
easy to ask people to say well it's easy
to ask them
what do you want in your life it's a
very hard question to answer because
it's too vague and Grand Day so we help
in the future authoring program we help
people break that down it's okay so
here's here's the situation so you put
yourself in the right frame of mind so
what's the right frame of mind it's like
rule two in this book treat yourself
like you're someone responsible for
helping you're someone that you are
responsible for helping so what that
means is you have to start from the
presupposition that despite all your
flaws and insufficiencies that it's
worth having you around and that it
would be okay if things were better for
you so you need to take care of yourself
like you're taking care of someone you
care for so there's a bit of a
Detachment in that and then the next
thing is okay so now look three to five
years down the road okay you get to have
what you need and want assuming you're
being reasonable and that you actually
want it which means you're willing to
make the sacrifices that would that
would make it possible what do you mean
by reasonable well that's that's the
next thing well within your grasp that
would be something what if thumping is
out of your grasp but
you still push hard enough well then
then you need an incremental plan right
you need to break that goal down into
steps that's a crazy goal within a year
that's like you haven't even done the
work to master a skill yet yeah yeah
well that's it and you can have a
high-end goal and more power to you if
you do you need it well you need a
pathway to it absolutely you know if
you're if it's 10 stories up above you
you need a staircase to get there right
and so you have to build the staircase
too and so in the future authoring
program so you're asked first of all
okay here's you get to have what you
want and need that's the proposition but
you have to aim at it you have to Define
it name at it so here so then the first
thing is okay uh
if you could put your family together
the way you wanted it to be what would
that look like and so that might be your
siblings and your parents but that also
might be you know your wife or your
husband and your kids assuming that
you're at that point in your life you
could have the family you wanted what
would that look like right okay
career same thing you get to have the
career or the job that that is within
your grasp necessary and and suitable
for for you if you were taking care of
yourself how are you going to educate
yourself because you're not as smart as
you should be there's a lot more things
you need to know so you got to keep
learning and moving forward so you need
to plan for that how are you going to
take care of yourself mentally and
physically right so
um how are you going to avoid the the
catastrophic Temptations For example of
drugs and alcohol because that pulls a
lot of people down you need a plan for
that you're going to be a social Drinker
how much are you going to drink how much
is too much what about your drug use you
gotta regulate that so it isn't a
pitfall how are you going to use your
time meaningful and productively outside
of work because you need to plan for
that
so that's
um and there's one other that that says
yeah I think there's seven initial
questions and I don't I don't remember
the last one
um oh intimate relationship of course so
you have you do you want do you want a
long-term stable intimate relationship
and if you do then how would you like
that to lay itself out you got to have a
vision for that because if you don't
have a vision you're not going to aim at
it and if you don't aim at it then you
won't even see the opportunities when
they arise that's the thing that's so
cool I wrote about this in chapter 10
which is be precise in your speech it's
a chapter about the fact that
aims structure your perceptions so for
example once you aim at something your
brain literally the perceptual
structures in your brain in your visual
cortex reorient themselves to calculate
a pathway to the aim and then what they
show you in the world is obstacles to
that path and and open Pathways to the
path that's actually how the world
reveals itself just like just like when
you're driving in a car and you have a
map and you or you aim at a particular
place then all the things that are
related to that place show up in the
world it's exactly the same thing yeah
because you are traveling through time
and space right and you need a map
so so after you answer these seven
questions and you're encouraged to do it
badly because you don't have to get a
perfectionistic just complete it right
because a bad plan is better than no
plan gives you something to improve so
even if your aim is vague and even if
it's off Target if you start aiming and
you see you're off Target then you can
shift and you can make it more precise
it's hard to recognize what you don't
want in that yes exactly exactly I
thought I wanted this but I don't so let
me re-navigate and figure out what I do
exactly and you might have to try a
bunch of things well you will have to
you can be that's why you shouldn't get
perfectionistic about it you will
absolutely be wrong but you won't be as
wrong as you would have been if you were
aimless right right so it's a so there's
a bit of human no man's land is worse
than no man's room is worse than a bad
path yeah that's exactly right oh I like
that that's a good one that's a good one
and it's right it's right you don't want
to be in no man's land why did you use
that phrase because that's right that's
exactly right I think um
for me the idea of walking around
aimlessly is like the worst idea in the
world it's like zero purpose zero
Mission zero certainty at all it's like
walking around in no man's land right
aimlessly but it's funny too because in
no man's land everybody's shooting at
you all right because that's a military
term and no man's land is the space
you bet so if you're aimless you're also
at a place where everything is shooting
at you rule number five aim high so
Japan he's a good guy
he has a kitten you know the kitten
likes him he makes puppets and he's a
humble person and he knows that compared
to the ideal that he's attempting to
subscribe to that he's
he's not abased before it or anything
like that he's not despicable in
relationship to it but the reason he's
on his knees is because the thing he's
pointing at is above him you know if he
it wouldn't be the right aim if it
wasn't above him and so the fact that
he's on his knees so to speak is only an
indication that his aim is proper
because you should be on your knees to
something that you actually admire
and if you don't feel like being on your
knees in front of it then perhaps you
don't actually admire it and then that
means you haven't got the stage set
properly it could be it should be
something that fills you with awe your
aim should should be at something that
fills you with awe because whatever why
why do something else well perhaps
because it's easy and perhaps because
it's malevolent and all of those things
but but those are no answer to the
problems that beset you they just make
things worse and that's clear
and so then Geppetto have his having
made his pact his Covenant just like
Abraham he falls into a dream right he
falls into a dream and the rest of the
movie actually takes place in a dream
and it's a Dream It's The Dream Within
which transformation takes place and
that's laid out at least in part-time
stops in in the Pinocchio story and
everything happens to Pinocchio in some
sense in a land that's outside of normal
time and that's that's the infinite
archetypal space and that's a real place
that's a real place the infinite and the
finite coexist and most of the time
we're in the place of the finite but
that doesn't mean that the places the
infinite doesn't exist it just means
that we can't get access to it we just
get intimations of it from time to time
you know when things are going perfectly
well for you on those rare occasions
where everything comes together for the
brief moment you inhabit that Divine
place and you have some sense of what
your life could be like if you organized
it from the smallest element to the
largest element and that's a place that
you can inhabit if not forever in a
manner that at least felt like forever
well because of Geppetto's decision the
Transcendent manifests itself and takes
the form of the Blue Fairy here that's
the positive element of nature right so
we could say well nature
it's not so clear that she's on your
side right she's the Red Queen in Alice
in Wonderland who runs around screaming
when you go down the rabbit hole who
runs around screaming off with their
heads and who says In My Kingdom you
have to run as fast as you can just to
stay in the same place
that's mother nature but then we might
say well how do we know that Mother
Nature's attitude towards you isn't
negative because your attitude towards
things isn't proper and that's what this
film attempts to indicate the idea is
that if you aim properly then nature
aligns itself behind you
now it also arrays itself in front of
you perhaps even as an antagonist but
the power that it it it provides you
with from within might be sufficient to
overcome it from without
and I think that
I think that the clinical evidence is
clear about that because one of the
things that we do know is that if you
take people who are confronting
terrible things and shrinking from them
and you teach them how to structure
their behavior so that they can advance
with courage
everything works better for them
their fears decrease and their character
grows
and so there might be enough of nature
within us to help us withstand the
nature that's outside of us and it
depends at least to some degree and how
it is that we Orient ourselves in the
world to some in to some unknowable
degree
now
Geppetto wants an autonomous individual
as a son
and that's also something that makes him
a great person because
autonomous individuals have their own
will and if you're a tyrant it's the
last thing that you're going to want and
if you're the Tyrant who's jealous of
his son it's even more so the last thing
you're ever going to want and so to aim
high and to want the development of the
autonomous individual are the same thing
and I would say that's the core story in
some sense of Western culture is that to
aim high and to develop the autonomous
individual or the same thing
and that's what happens in Pinocchio
that's what happens in the story of
Abraham
and the transformation takes place the
magical transformation and in the
Pinocchio story one of the things that's
so interesting about it and this is part
of its mythological substructure from
the scientific perspective there's only
two determining forces with regards to
the destiny of the individual there's
nature deterministic and culture
deterministic
and then Scholars Wrangle about which of
those is the greater force but in
mythological stories there's always a
third element and that third element is
something like autonomous Consciousness
and there's no place for autonomous
Consciousness in the deterministic story
of Nature and culture but we all act as
if autonomous Consciousness is the
primary reality and the biblical stories
are predicated on the idea that
autonomous Consciousness is what gives
rise to the world and I don't think that
we're in a position to presume that that
is necessarily an error and so what that
means is to aim high and to develop the
autonomous individualists
is simultaneously the decision to
formulate an allegiance with the the
conscious power that brings being into
existence rule number six pursue your
goals there's this idea in jungian
Psychology called the circumambulation
and Jung had this idea that you had a
potential future self which would be in
potential everything that you could be
and that it manifests itself moment to
moment in your present Life by making
you interested in things and the things
that you're interested in are the things
that would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development
now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even but but
it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that with fully expand you as a
well-adapted creature well like there's
nothing radical about that idea how well
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you that is what the
situation would be it's kind of
interesting to think about how that
would be manifest moment to moment but
the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down the path of
development
well that better be the case Okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the Call to
Adventure let's say
so and the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places now the problem with
the Call to Adventure is like what the
hell do you know
you might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent
and often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
grip their interests say they do it very
badly and shortly
and so you stumble around like an idiot
when you try to do something new that's
why the fool is the precursor to the
Savior from the from the symbolic
perspectives because you have to be a
fool before you can be a master and if
you're not willing to be a fool then you
can't be a master so
so you're gonna it's an error error
written process and that's also laid out
in the Old Testament stories because the
first thing that happens to all these
patriarchal figures when God kicks them
out of their father's house when they're
like 84 is that they they run into all
sorts of trouble and some of it's social
and some of it's natural and some of
it's a consequence of their own moral
inadequacy so they're fools and but but
the thing that's so interesting is that
despite the fact that they're fools
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straighten themselves out across
time
and so it's something like this this
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero it's
just not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Nitric called that a will
to stupidity which I really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all and
that's the continual message that Echoes
through these historical stories in
Genesis it's like these are flawed
people they they should have got the
hell out of their house way before they
did
um and they go out and they stumble
around in tyranny and famine and
self-betrayal and and
violence and but it's a hell of a lot
better than just rotting away at home
angle number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is stay
sane you need structure you need
predictability and you need more of it
than you think just to keep you sane now
if you're lucky and and maybe a bit odd
you can deviate five percent from the
norm or ten percent from the norm or
something like that carefully and
cautiously as long as the rest of you is
all well ordered in a normative manner
you might be able to get away with that
and you might be able to sustain it
across time and people might be able to
tolerate you if you do it or maybe
you'll get really lucky and you happen
to be creative but reasonably well put
together and people will actually be
happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you but
even under those circumstances mostly
what you want is to
have a routine it's disciplined it's
predictable and bloody well stick to it
you're going to be way healthier and
happier and saner if you do that and
then the other thing that you need
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalyst got wrong I think is that
they overestimated the degree to which
sanity was a consequence of internal of
being properly structured internally you
know
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view you're sort of an ego and that ego
is inside you and of course it rests on
an unconscious structure but the purpose
of psycho and Analysis is to sort out
that unconscious structure and the ego
on top of it and to make you a fully
functioning and autonomous individual
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important the
reason that you're saying if you're
aware if you have a well-organized
unconscious and ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue and so what
people are doing to each other all the
time just non-stop is broadcasting
sanity signals back and forth right it's
like you smile at people if they're well
if they're not not only behaving
properly but behaving in a way that you
would like to see them continue to
behave you frown at them if they're not
you ignore them if they're not you shun
them you you roll your eyes at them you
manifest a disgust face you don't listen
to them you interrupt them you won't
cooperate with them you won't compete
with them it's like you're blasting
signals of other people about how to
regulate their behavior are so
frequently well it just makes up all of
your social interaction that's why we
face each other and we have emotional
displays on our face and we're looking
at each other's eyes and we know exactly
we know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their Consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself as a
credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape
making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane and so
what happens to people too if they don't
have a routine and they get isolated as
they start to drift and they drift badly
because the world is too complicated for
you to keep it organized all by yourself
you just cannot do it so a lot of our so
we Outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
Outsource the problem of Sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time it's like a stock market for sanity
and it's partly and I use that I use
that definition with purpose because the
stock market does the same kind of
impossible thing right because it tries
to price things which is impossible
there's how many things are there like a
billion how in the world do you decide
what the price is you can't decide what
the price is that's why you have a stock
market I said well in a free market I
mean for for consumer goods is
everyone's voting on what the price of
everything is all the time and that's
the way we figured out because it's
actually it's technically impossible
that's partly why the stock market
explodes now and then and there's
Bubbles and all that sort of thing but
anyways the point is
things are chaotic in Alice in
Wonderland when Ellis goes down the
rabbit hole
that's the underworld right
so now she's gone into the substructure
of being
and she meets the red queen and the Red
Queen is Mother Nature
and mother nature is running around
yelling off with their heads off with
her heads
which is of course what Mother Nature
does and she tells Ellis in My Kingdom
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place
and that's exactly right and that's a
description of
in fact evolutionary biologists
psychologists have picked up on that
phrase they call it the Red Queen
problem and the Red Queen problem is
everything's after you all the time and
you're not smart enough to do anything
about it or enough about it
and so that's a permanent existential
problem so how do you deal with that
you've got a biological structure
so your embodiment is part of the
solution to the problem and then you're
enculturated
and because you're enculturated
so you're taught a lot of things that
you need to know but mostly what you're
taught is how to communicate with other
people in an acceptable manner and then
once you can communicate with people in
an acceptable manner then you can
Outsource your problems constantly but
you're doing constantly and so we're in
this continual Dynamic exchange of
problem solving so if you're a
socialized person that's what you get
access to and that's something to know
if you're going to have kids and I
mentioned this I think in a previous
lecture
per the purpose of being a parent for
very young children is to make your
children
exceptionally socially desirable by the
age of four because if you can do that
they're set because everyone wants them
around and as soon as everybody wants
them around they want to play with them
they want to cooperate when they want to
compete with them it's like the door is
open the door is open and they stay sane
because they've got all sorts of people
who actually like them that are helping
them out and so that's your goal is to
make them as socially acceptable as you
possibly can socially desirable as you
possibly can and that doesn't mean
you render them obedient without Spirit
right that's that's a tyrants mode of of
enforcing social acceptability it's like
never do anything wrong well that's not
any way to I mean that's a good piece of
advice you know like but
it's missing the other half which is do
a bunch of things that are right so that
so that people are thrilled to have you
around and to and encourage that that's
what you want to do as a parent as well
as inculcating the order and so you know
and in this little diagram I indicated
that there's God the Father with the son
behind him and he's ruling over this
walled City so he's like The Meta Spirit
of the walled City
it's very very nice very nice image
brilliant image so it's is the
collective Spirit of the city that's
another way of thinking about it or the
collective Spirit of the city across
time or the collective Spirit of the
force that built and maintained the city
across time even better and that's
associated with the sun because it's a
it's it's it's associated with
Enlightenment and illumination and all
of those things that we associate with
higher Consciousness and vision it's a
brilliant image and then I overlaid this
you know now of course the the
patriarchal
aspect of existence can become
tyrannical
it does that quite regularly it's one of
the existential dangers of human
civilization is that Civilization is a
medication for chaos but it can spin out
of control in and of itself and become
its own sort of problem which is like a
hyper order problem generally which then
produces a chaos problem so every
solution carries within it certain
problems right because no solution is
perfect and so you have to keep things
in Balance but it's one of the reasons
that I'm really uh
let's call it irritated about the
postmodernists because they keep
yammering about the patriarchy and it's
very very annoying because because it's
self-evident that social structures are
tyrannical it's like that's not news
folks that's obvious but that's not all
they are and it's it's the it's the
reduction of the entire
complex
solution let's say to a uni-dimensional
problem it's just tyranny it's like no
actually it's not just tyranny if you
spent six months somewhere that was just
tyranny you'd know the difference very
very rapidly and that doesn't mean that
everyone doesn't give up a pound or two
or ten or Twenty of Flesh to participate
even in a society that's as free as a
western Society is we all get crushed
and molded by the tyrannical force of
social convention
but at least in principle the benefit is
worth the cost and then it's also up to
you to make sure that you don't
sacrifice more to the group than you
should and you can start to tell if
you're sacrificing more to the group
than you should because you start to
become resentful of other people that's
part of that that's part of the
psychological mechanism that's informing
you of that so it's up to you to fight
against the you know the overarching
pressure for Conformity to retain your
individual logos let's say but that's
sort of your problem it's like the group
wants you to behave
now if you could behave and be
creatively productive so much the better
but that's pretty damn rare so the group
generally tends to settle just for
behave and there's a tyrannical element
of that but what the hell is the
alternative it's you know our society is
based on consensus and the consensus is
based on the sacrifice of a certain
sacrifice of individuality even though
individuality is absolutely necessary as
a revitalizing force for this Society
you don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there we have two as far as I'm
concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they'd get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying uh watching things on YouTube
that not only do you not want to watch
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know what you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient 20
times more efficient that's the Pareto
distribution you have no idea how
efficient efficient people get it's
completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well there's nine billion
seven billion people in the world we're
going to Peak at about 9 billion by the
way and then it'll decline rapidly but
seven billion people in the world and
who are you you're just one little dust
moat among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the Martyr so that's a pretty
good deal All Things Considered
especially when they are when the
alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century you
have to make a decision in your life and
this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being as good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them I don't think it's
unreasonable to assume that that's how
you elicit the best from them the best
that can be elicited you're going to get
hurt sometimes and betrayed but that's
going to happen no matter what approach
you take I think that's the most
effective approach and that is perhaps
the most effective approach to existence
per se to approach it with love and
courage and and so that's how that looks
to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable that
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities self-confidence comes from
doing difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it it's too hard it's too
difficult it's too scary
most people let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry can't see
we had like you see some here behind me
it's like look and see that mountain of
snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to wacon and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
gonna do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why is nobody still Blowfish like I
gotta get over there I got a backpack on
I'm rocking I'm sweating like crazy I'm
already exhausted now I gotta go through
this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snoped your
knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you're not
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
yeah I'm walking through I'm freezing uh
I'm taking one kind of giant step at a
time snow is getting all through my
boots all down my legs I I almost slip
and fall I have a coffee that I that I
picked up uh it's dripping all over the
place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go Evan you got this man
let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
on my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some epic Jordan Peterson
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there
and what Jung pointed out which I really
liked was that that wasn't an injunction
to be nice to other people it was an
invitation to reciprocity it was
something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated